[Music]
when everyone believes in something you
think that it should be true
but you might be surprised to learn that
almost everyone is wrong while only a
few people are right if you want to be
one of these smart cookies and impress
all your friends you will have to watch
this video until the end if this is your
first time visiting our channel don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we are showing you five lives that
you still believe five Pepsi and
coca-cola tastes the same this has been
the biggest debate of all time whenever
you go to a bar or a restaurant you ask
the waitress if you can have some Coca
Cola and she tells you that she only has
Pepsi that's not what you wanted but she
adds that it's the same but you know
that there is a reason why your favorite
drink is called rum and coke not rum and
Pepsi but who is actually right in this
story many people have been interested
in this question and there is truly a
difference between Pepsi and Coca Cola
coke has a kind of raisiny vanilla taste
and slightly more sodium than their
competitor with slightly more sugar
Pepsi is sweeter than coke and also
characterized by a citrusy flavor burst
there are also mysterious differences
that no one really understands because
some ingredients are secret but when you
ask people to identify the two brands
they usually can't tell the difference
during blind taste tests and that
doesn't keep people from having strong
preferences even if the two drinks have
really similar chemical compositions so
what explains that someone might prefer
Coca Cola over Pepsi it's all about
brandy cokes brand is more valuable and
that's why it usually wins if people
don't know the brand they will prefer
Pepsi so whether you thought that these
two brands were the same or not you were
not absolutely wrong for urine is good
against jellyfish stings if so many
people believe this it's probably
because they watched an episode of
friends mana can reveal the story of
when Chandler had to pee on her leg too
use the pain and swelling from a
jellyfish sting now that we watched the
show we have never seen so many people
using urine to solve their problems at
the beach but is this natural remedy
actually a good solution you might be
surprised to learn that there is
actually no evidence that urine can heal
a jellyfish sting all we have is
personal antidotes of people who believe
that it works it takes a lot of courage
to admit that you peed on yourself so
they can at least be proud of that but
why do people believe this people think
that the ecstatic ph of urine helps
break down the toxin and reduce pain and
it is true that the venom is really
alkaline and that it can only be
neutralized with acidic compounds so it
makes sense the pee on yourself right
but the problem is that urine is not
always acidic because the pH changes
depending on what you eat and drink and
even if you have the most acidic tea in
the world it won't be enough to
neutralize the pain all these stories
your friends told you were just about
the placebo effect next time use vinegar
and baking soda instead of using your
own urine that will be a better story to
tell 3 the earth is round don't worry
we're not going to say that the earth is
flat even though many people believe in
this theory they came up with strange
arguments like that Antarctica is a wall
of ice around the rim and that NASA is
guarding it to prevent people from
climbing and falling off the planet we
know that this doesn't make sense
but you are wrong too when you tell them
that the earth is round in this case you
might think that it is simply not a
perfect sphere because of the mountains
and anything else higher or lower than
the sea level and you would be right but
we are actually talking about something
more important than 8000 meters on a
planet with a radius of more than 6000
kilometers what changes the shape of our
planet is actually that it's spinning
this is what makes it fatter in the
middle and squashed at its poles what we
call an oblate spheroid and earth is not
the only
that is not round anything that is
spinning will look more like an oblate
spheroid and we knew about that for a
long time as Isaac Newton is the first
who came up with this theory however
just like it took people some time to
understand that earth is round we think
that you'll have to give your friends
some time to accept that it's actually
an oblate spheroid - you need eight
hours of sleep did you ever wonder why
you still feel tired after eight hours
of sleep it feels like you could just be
sleeping all day the main thing that
could explain this is that people have
been lying to you when they said that
you needed eight hours of sleep so why
do we hear that everywhere people use
the number eight like it's the solution
to all our problems and the reason why
we are upset during the morning and it
all started when scientists found out
that people sleep on average seven point
five hours during the week and eight
point five hours during the weekends but
people wanted a perfect number so they
said that we needed eight hours of sleep
to be in shape and the reason why it
will never work is that everyone is
different we don't have the same genes
we don't have the same age we didn't do
the same thing all day and we don't all
need to sleep for eight hours you simply
need as much sleep as you need and there
is no perfect number just try to go to
bed when you are sleepy and you will see
that you're maybe sleeping more or less
than eight hours try to understand how
much sleep you usually need and this is
how you're going to plan when you're
going to go to bed listening to your
body is the best solution Guaymas Diet
Coke is better than coca-cola if you
love coca-cola and want to go on a diet
you might try Diet Coke soft drinks are
never a good way to lose weight but you
could at least say that you tried and
that it could make a difference but did
you know that Diet Coke is actually
worse than coca-cola and Diet Coke sugar
is replaced with fake sweeteners like
aspartame sucralose and saturon you
might think that there are fewer
calories in these things but it actually
messes with your body's ability to
process the calories from sweet things
this is what makes it harder for us to
metabolize the sugar we get from food we
eat something sweet so our body is ready
to get more energy but sucralose just
passes through us and our body wants us
to eat something else with sugar this is
what increases the risk of obesity
metabolic syndrome and type 2 diabetes
this is why you should avoid anything
that is sweet
has zero calories it just doesn't make
sense and your body was not made to
drink that if you want to go on a diet
drink water and try to eat something
healthy there is no way coca-cola is
ever going to be healthy
are there other lies that people still
believe don't be shy to tell us the
truth in the comment section down below
we'd love to hear what you think and
that's it for 5 lies you still believe
for more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 ridiculous assumptions people
still believe today thanks for watching
and see you next time
[Music]